que fait un héros de guerre comme vous à
cambrioler des planques dans ma ville
j'avais pas de quoi acheter des
médicaments
[Musique]
que je puisse vous aider
il y a une prison qui se situait à
l'extérieur de la ville ce que j'attends
c'est que vous y allez
et que vous me dégotiez des preuves de
violation des droits de l'homme et je
vous jure qu'après ça je vous libère
il n'y a que comme ça que vous reverrez
votre fille
tu fais partie du système
[Musique]
tu auras besoin d'allier je vais la
jouer au solo j'espère que cette
bataille
un grand cœur et ça se voit mais si tu
veux survivre faut encore que tu
t'améliores le directeur
je contrôle tout de A à Z
dans bouche
comme des animaux et en plus ils veulent
qu'on se battre
tu es devenu
peut-être qui te fait peur moi il y a
personne qui me fait peur
tu fais partie du système maintenant tu
partiras quand je l'aurais décidé je
compte bien faire tomber cette
je veux juste revoir ma fille
et qu'est-ce que tu comptes faire
connard